everything American is generally bigger
than what we have and therefore probably
better
Laffy Taffy this is a survey to flavor
mystery swirl oh it's very sticky to the
rack oh god this is review helps opening
that and attempting to disentangle from
the wrapping is dramatic this is a
perfect thing to give a four year old
just before they go to bed yeah I can
eat like five of these and then go do
some crimes
I know preservatives and always fat-free
I'm trying to untwist it if you use it
as a straw devour their taste is like an
aftertaste isn't it it's just it's like
I feel like they're quite nothing there
is no flavor this is a Halloween sweet
there was an episode Sabrina the Teenage
Witch in which they have unlimited candy
corn
I saw the package I was like Jelly Belly
nice and it's not I'm doing - yeah so it
kind of tastes like play-doh I always
saw there without stuff there when I saw
them on TV
I thought they were kind of like Swick
years of marshmallowy do you think the
different colors have different flavors
yellow phenomena
no but it just tastes of despair I never
understand spray being a thing this way
just doesn't get me started you get a
weird freshness Awards minute consuming
large quantities within a brief period
may cause temporary irritation to
sensitive that was a bad idea just
anything six glass of dark you'll be you
know bouncing off the walls to the
police carry that America does
incredible I go Percival oohs Wow